*Dan stares unblinkingly*
"CATS" ends with Old Deuteronomy, played by Judi Dench, explaining to the audience that,
now that they have witnessed the Jellicle Ritual, they should require
no further explanation, no longer require
an interpreter to the Jellicle Ways.
Few things could be further from the truth.
I feel utterly unprepared to talk about Cats on its own terms
because I don't know these songs. I don't know
these characters. I'm not familiar with this story and, very clearly, Cats has no interest in
aiding the uninitiated.
There is a character, a stripey white cat
that is abandoned in a junkyard at the start of the film,
who fills the space that would normally be occupied by
an audience surrogate. I think her name is Liz...?
I should and will look it up, but it's fairly incidental and,
unlike most of the other cats, she
doesn't get an entire musical number that mostly consists of saying her own name repeatedly.
She was definitely named after a queen...
She is an outsider to the local culture of the cats who occupy this neighborhood,
providing an opportunity for the locals to explain the way of things.
Indeed, these explanations make up the
bulk of  the musical numbers,  the show largely consisting of a series of
cats explaining who they are to Liz and the audience.
The problem is that the explanations, for the most part,
are all nonsense. This is not accidental,
the show is mostly Seussian nonsense words and
freeform absurdity, but 109
minutes of nonsense is, to say the least,
a little unmooring.
Maybe that's the joke. Now you understand
the Jellicle Ways of Jellicle Cats, but
... you don't. And you never will, because
you can't. You've been Punk'd.
What I have pieced together is that the cats have convened for
a ritual where Old Deuteronomy picks a worthy cat who gets
to be reborn.
I don't want to interrogate the metaphysics
of Andrew Lloyd Weber's Cats because canon
is an abyss deeper than the Uncanny Valley Cats lives in,
but at some point I *believe* it was mentioned that this
process, the balloon trip to the Heaviside Layer,
erases memories, which strikes me as
making this ritual death not much
different from  regular death.
Anyway, it turns out a lot of cats are really
eager to die.
The winner is a cat that everyone hates,
for reasons I was unable to parse. I guess
at some point in the past she teamed up with local villain
Macavity, who was either a prankster or a
serial killer. The closest thing to an evolving plot consists
of Macavity kidnapping
the various death candidates so that he,
as the sole remaining candidate, can win by default.
His plan is foiled and the cat that everyone
hates wins and gets to die, but, in a good way. What is happening is
pretty simple, even if why
remains beyond human ken.
This stuff, though, this is the easy stuff.
This is just what you get when you sign up to see Cats.
You're not really there for plot. You're there for
music and dancing. Dancing and film have an
odd relationship and it's probably no
coincidence that the prevalence of dance in
film has become increasingly niche as cinema has grown more sophisticated.
The beauty of performance dance is in the physicality,
that you are watching people
do something with their bodies at the very edges of
human performance.
When we live in an age where cinema can effortlessly
fake performance,
it gets a lot more difficult to persuade the audience that
what they're seeing is impressive,
and it becomes altogether impossible when
every human's body has been
replaced with a cartoon cat skin.
And this is well and truly where everything goes off the rails.
Cats is a film seated so firmly at the bottom
of the Uncanny Valley that it has set up residences,
sown and harvested wheat, raised children, and
developed its own system of divine mathematics.
In addition to the digital skin, the actual
physical feats of dancers are coarsely
blended with total cartoon replacements,
having the too-precise movements of a Fortnite emote.
One of the first shots of the film features Robert
Fairchild's human face hovering in front of his cat head like a cardboard
Halloween mask, an unfinished effect that
crops up several times in the movie, most
extensively in a sequence involving singing and dancing mice and
cockroaches with human faces.
Rebel Wilson eats several of the cockroaches.
Speaking of Rebel Wilson, not
once but twice in the film, she unzips her
digital cat skin and steps out to reveal
the same cat skin, but now wearing
a sequin vest and shorts combo, like a
Vegas cigarette girl from the '70s. The effect
is so unsettling that I felt my own skin trying to escape.
Cats has a very odd relationship with clothes.
Some cats wear them, others don't.
It's maybe a little weird, but a fairly
innocuous theatrical convention that is FAR
from the hardest thing in this film to adjust to...
at least, until those cats take their clothes off.
Idris Elba's Macavity spends the majority of the film
wearing a giant fur coat and it is impossible to describe just how
uncomfortable it is
when he suddenly apparates wearing nothing at all.
Despite the plethora of cats on screen
who aren't wearing clothes, the act of disrobing
shattered the convention.
It becomes nudity, and a nudity that
feels so bizarrely unintentional that,
despite it being deliberately recorded for
all future human generations to see,
the instinct is to politely look away in
embarrassment and respect for Mr. Elba's modesty
as though director Tom Hooper had
somehow managed to sneak up behind him and
steal his clothes. These moments
tend to have a knock-on effect that sharply calls attention to
all the cats on screen and, like an optical illusion,
a switch is flipped in the brain, and suddenly
they're ALL naked. A room full
of naked human cats writhing and yowling.
The film is permeated with a subtextual horniness that is made
unsettling by virtue of being subtextual,
by virtue of a disconnect
between the subject of the script and the subject of the camera.
These are not songs about sex
and seduction, but nevertheless cats
thrust their Ken-doll-smooth genitals
at the audience, splay their legs and
end multiple musical numbers laying on the floor in a
post-orgasmic heap.
Everyone who sees Cats will have their own reaction,
their own moment that becomes seared
into their being for the rest of time like
prophets of old glimpsing the true face of God.
I, for one, am unable
to express in words the scream
that emanated from deep within my soul
when Judi Dench's Old Deuteronomy
spreads her legs wide and
scissors them in the air to express her approval of
another cat's musical number.